le concours supporters très bien on a
commencé dès le mois d'avril avec douze
candidates qui ont débuté donc les
différents ateliers de préparation tout
ce qui est cours de maquillage cours de
démarche de maintien est aujourd'hui
qu'elles font leur première séance photo
cette année c'est l'année où nous avons
le plus de candidats de l'année dernière
ils étaient onze
et cette année il y en a une de plus
chaque année on a de plus en plus de
personnes qui viennent à l'élection
l'année dernière on a fait salle comble
et jette on espère que ces derniers se
sera paré et que voulez vous démontrera
organisons une telle manifestation
on veut montrer que les femmes sont
comme toutes les femmes et les gonzes
qu'elles ont le droit de participer à
des concours de bouthillier qu'elles ont
le droit de faire partie du milieu de la
mode comme tout le monde parce que nous
sommes d'abord des femmes
le club tomber les tabous c'est cela
aujourd'hui également c'est le l'objet
de notre shooting d'une séance photo de
casser les tabous de casser tous les
préjugés qu'on peut avoir sur sur les
familles